Mí sẽ phong tự tên lửa mini-man tree từ cân cử vàn giữa bấc, bằng khí phong nhà.
Hương đen khu thường nghiệm trên đạo xanh hô, khó trời lành, thái bình dương.
Đây là vô từ A7M thứ 2 trong năm nay của Mỹ, sau lần phòng muốn tên lửa chuyên dân chưa,
dify từ tong ngăn hạm nhân hội tháng chính.
Bộn án lộn Mỹ trở biết với cuộc thủ nghiệm sắp tới không kích nổ đồ đàn.
Mà chỉ đến sát tình ổn định và khả năng phản nướng quảy thống trong tình hủ thử cây.
Con theo không quân Mỹ, trên trình phòng tự mini-man tree là hoàn động định kì,
nhằm suy trì năng lực dân đẹp nhân án tòàn và đáng tìm cây.
Dạc quan sát trở sàng việc Mỹ nói lại thình em A7M,
dễ dân ra chung mối cảnh nha và Trung Quốc đều tăng cường phát triển bố khí chính lực mới,
làm dấy lên lòng ngày, với một dưới đoạn cảnh chính hạm nhân căn thẳng hơn trong thời gian tới.